they told me I couldn't build the
medieval McDonald's they were proud I
never I never seen art in such a
profound way until I played Viking
McDonald's simulator 2015 are these the
meat oh Jesus
man I know how to flip some burgers man
Jesus look alike we gonna make a sale
for little burger bad I'm Adam don't
just make burgers come we have to make
in July maybe a vote no okay fine what
did you do all these burgers are burnt
they look like hockey pucks hey I'm
making the burger on the leg
god damn rats I'll get you one day I'll
get you I'm gonna [ __ ] murder you oh
oh hey there sorry let's don't worry
that's just our pets
what the [ __ ] are you
you're making it bats what our intern is
mentally challenged now all our
ingredients are a [ __ ] dirty our
[ __ ] dirty man some say if the meat
looks like a hockey puck you shouldn't
need it
I say Yolo it's like an Oreo that's
great not this is my specialty I call it
cancer in a burger
got a problem with my burger what is
this [ __ ] who thought not god damn it
who thought that was a good idea
I'll go advertise good be naked sex say
cells what is intern doing intern intern
trying to break 3 I have a new bucks to
fight the other box
[ __ ] [ __ ] why you leaving why are they
leaving what's wrong with our food hey
I'm coming with samples
oh sure this game is like Skyrim